[Musique]
c'était l'interview choc diffusé en mars
dernier qui avait retourné tout
buckingham je ne voulais plus moi je ne
voulais plus être en vie
c'était une pensée claire
réel effrayante un entretien entre le
couple principe mégane et harry et
l'animatrice américaine oprah winfrey
watts durant cette interview le couple
avait fait de nombreuses révélations au
sujet de la famille royale et avait
notamment dénoncé des faits de racisme
au moment de l'accouchement de mégane et
il y avait aussi
inquiétés des conversations sur la
couleur de sa peau quand ils mettraient
si aucun membre de la famille n'avait
été cité un ouvrage paru il ya quelques
jours révèle que c'est bien le prince
charles qui aurait soufflé cette phrase
à sa femme camilla lors d'un petit
déjeuner une phrase que le prince
charles dément formellement c'est de la
fiction cas cela ne vaut pas la peine
que l'on fasse plus de commentaires à ce
sujet voilà de quoi raviver un peu plus
les tensions au sein de la famille
royale
[Applaudissements]
ami de la famille merial tes côtés même
si le roi est encore un petit peu
fébrile mais il sera là dès lundi bien
évidemment
l'heure est grave voire très grave que
se passe-t-il dans la famille royale est
d'abord vous croyez vous qui êtes un
amoureux des monarchies et de cette
monarchie en particulier à ces
accusations de racisme alors nouveau
rififi chez les windsor du
rythme à leurs excuses il croit il va
falloir nuancer mes propos mais ce n'est
pas te temps de commencer comme ça ça
veut dire que mon attention totalement
impossible il y a en autre en angleterre
qui court à travers une illustre royaume
puisqu'il s'agit un peu d'un conte de
fées et on dit en angleterre que il il
existe deux femmes dans le monde il ya
celle de dieu il règne sur le ciel il y
a les windsor y règne sur les offres 130
millions de sujets quand même sur lequel
règne isabelle où je vous parle de cela
pour vous dire qu'ubs les windsor certes
c'est en clan qui est médiatique qui est
fascinant qui est rutilant par les
bijoux mais c'est surtout le clan le
plus fermé du monde le clan le plus
fermé de lattes ça veut dire qu'on ne
sait pas ce qui s'y passe on ne sait pas
on ne sait pas vraiment ce qui s'y passe
mais il est très difficile de pénétrer
chez de windsor il y à ce qu'on appelle
le cercle magique qui entoure la famille
royale qu'est ce que c'est le cercle
magique se dit qu'est ce que c'est le
cinq majeur
les gammes de nord qui entourait la
reine et qui par nargis presque pour
elle a touché il est inutile de vous
dire que le jour ils font cela ils
dégagent il me correspond rappelle qu'on
n'a pas le droit de toucher 1 à rennes
on ne touche pas à la reine mais c'est
pour fait alors comment toucher si on
veut
demande bien sûr
on démolit kerry quoi si on me demande
n'est pas viré sochala pour faire partie
de ce cercle magique il faut faire
partie des familles des plus anciennes
et les plus nobles de l' empire inutile
de vous dire qu'ils ont tellement le
sens bulleux qu'il ressemble à les
schtroumps
mais c'est loin d'être anecdotique c'est
pour vous dire donc il n'y a aucune
personne de couleur qui est venu dans
ces cercles c'est la vraie depuis 2010
est il y en a au lieutenant-colonel sur
d'ailleurs sur la demande du prince
charles d'accord yahoo qui à pied qui
provient du ghana qui en fait partie une
seule personne souffrant en staff que
l'on peut qualifier de 250 à 300
personnes se retrouvent sans personne il
ya une seule personne noire pour
m'exciter donc vraiment pas pour vous
dire que ce n'est pas tellement du
racisme par rapport à la couleur de peau
je pense vraiment que lorsque l'on naît
lorsque l'on est d'ailleurs windsor tout
ce qui est un peu différent vous paraît
suspect pourquoi parce qu'ils évoluent
dans un cercle qui est archi fermé mais
bertrand question est-ce que vous pensez
que réellement le prince charles a pu
s'interroger sur la couleur de peau de
ses petits-enfants sûr il a pu
s'interroger sur la couleur de peau tout
simplement comme quelqu'un demanderai
marir et son fils qui est roux a une
personne qui est métissé qui demandait
mais de quelle couleur exactement va
être la peau du bébé à naître
non ça ne me choque pas parce que vous
savez quoi le prince charles il est au
coeur du système et il sait très bien
cesser des inquiétudes qu'il formulait
aussi jean-michel mais ça ne choque
absolument personne mais j'ai bien où
cela vous met bien sûr que non j'ai
plein de couples mixtes dans mes amis
comme tout le monde et les parents eux
mêmes se demande à qui ressemblera plus
de bébés à la naissance il est ce qu'il
pourra plus de l'impression en fin de
contrat qu'il recèle sa paresse et ça va
être
c'est vraiment être
simplement dur
et la polémique mais parfois c'est dur à
s'interroger sur la teneur de sa fille
darina aulas mais quelle va être sa dans
les corons ce sont deux bons d'un essai
mais qu'est-ce que concert était
l'avocat a ainsi rappelé aux fruits
c'est avec un enfant que fatou tu te
prendrais pas s'il serait plus du côté
de fatou plus sa cote à la loupe et
battu serait le sol ou la couleur de
thriller sur les revoir dans l'exode de
caisse et de s'interroger sur la couleur
de peau oui c'est que bernard jazeera si
c'est d'être choqués par un mariage
mixte s'est pas de ce monde et acquiert
son enfant écouter la conversation
bonjour j'ai la sensation de toucher la
conversation éventuelle selon
christopher anderson oui voilà qui est
journaliste américain voilà
c'est très important c'est donc c'est
relayé par un journaliste certes
américain mais journalistes tout de même
il dit selon christopher andersen
l'incident se serait produit le 27
novembre 2010 sept jours de l'annoncé
des fiançailles du couple vous le savez
je me demande à quoi va ressembler
l'enfant aurait demandé le prince
charles et son épouse camilla elle a
répondu
interloqué et bien il sera absolument
magnifique j'en suis certaine et lui
répond je voulais dire à quoi
ressemblera le teint de l'enfant paraît
qu'en penses-tu aurait ajouté le duc de
cornouaille depuis les équipes du prince
charles ont qualifié publiquement ce
récit de pure fiction alors père tandis
qu'un journaliste spécialisé de la
couronne ont tenté de pénétrer à
kensington pour donc c'est là la date
des fiançailles immortaliser le couple
personne n'y est arrivé parmi les
journalistes aux royaux et monsieur
personne que personne ne connaît
évidemment
lui est parvenue il était même très très
proche de charles et camilla puisqu'il a
pu entendre cette conversation
permettez-moi vraiment d'en douter de
tout casser la
cci j'y suis quand même un peu fort
parce que c'est quand même lui qui l'a
je trouve il faut souligner sa permis à
meghan markle de remous willaya de la
chapelle de windsor sous les yeux du
monde entier trois milliards de
téléspectateurs tout de même parce que
son label unesco était dans la capacité
de pouvoir venir puisqu'il avait vendu
des photos c'est lucas minyard et sa
roue donc c c#
conduit lui-même meghan markle devant un
parterre de ce mmo n'est donc vers
quelqu'un qui seraient rasées h 30 je
vais essayer de titiller un peu bertrand
certains disent quand même que ce serait
une des raisons pour lesquelles mégane
et ariste se seraient exilés aux etats
unis est ce que vous y croyez à ça le
racisme while prince charles non je n'y
crois pas une seule seconde je pense
vraiment que au moment où elle met les
pieds chez les windsor meghan markle
sait déjà qu'elle va partir aller plus
loin je pense qu'il ya vraiment une
mégane voix qui a été calculée non
j'aime pas meghan markle vous savez
pourquoi parce que les spécialistes
royaux on sait nous ils ont dit à oprah
winfrey que donc il y avait comment dire
des led c'est cette phrase
malencontreuse qui avait été prononcée
par rapport à la couleur de la peau mais
évidemment ils n'ont pas souhaité dire
qu'ils s'étaient et nous étions
convaincus que non seulement va les
sortir non plus que ça allait viser le
prince charles pourquoi parce que ça ne
vise pas le prince charles savvis
l'institution royale vis à vis la
monarchie et c'est contre cela que je
suis lorsque megan veut saper vraiment
la couronne c'est son but et les mégane
merkel elle voulait retourner parce que
les américaines support de vivre aux
états unis tout le reste de la merde ça
n'existe pas ils veulent être aux états
unis social est à new york los angeles
il était nu c'est pas pour ça qu'elle a
voulu quitter mais c'est parce qu'elle
boulin pour nos états unis wam a bien
vous énervez pas
également que les nomades jusque là il
en a jusque là oui je sais faire que ça
fait du bien de voir jean michel maire
qui survole ce débat et tu as raison
jean mi je n'en peux plus de ce procès
on est morte mais n'importe quoi c'est
absolument moi je pense que c'est une
polémique politique c'est à dire qu'il
ya d'un côté les us qui sont
progressistes et walk it et de l'autre
côté vous voyez vous aller jusque-là
gouvernement la tradition la monarchie
alors oui effectivement je pense que si
on dit par exemple que l'enfant est le
portrait craché du père eh ben c'est pas
parce qu'on est anti blancs ou anti
noirs ou raciste et c'est même pas du
sec gym n'a pas l'air vraiment
gêné après après guillon on banalise les
questions essentielles sur la couleur de
peau appartenant à s'interroge sur une
couleur de peau
brian au sein de la ceni aucun problème
je
ne suis pas de la famille royale oui
mais si c'est volontaire et voulons plus
rose
c'est qu'il ya il ya une interrogation
excusez mon mieux a banalisé racistes au
toit gilles pardon mais on voit la
définition du mot rapide aux racistes et
discriminés quelqu'un en raison de sa
couleur de peau grasse et sarthe ont
écouté nos routes on a l'impression que
le simple fait d'évoquer le fait que
quelqu'un est métisse clair de peau
blanc noirci star viendra si cela mais
si on a un parent brun et une part en
blond on peut se demander si l'enfant
sera bon pourquoi on ferait passer à
toulouse le mans on est plausible et
jean michel mercier les chaussures le
plateau le public a applaudi jean michel
gilles guillaume des rires oui le canada
a maintenant plus raison sans michel
aussi c'est toi qui rendra site les gens
donnent
lavallée
invraisemblable étudie tout le monde en
même temps les halles isabelle roy et
son dernier rang jean lassalle au pire
la secren suis toi ouais tout le monde a
dit mais c'est en fait blanc cela
commençait ce tout le monde a été
surpris qu'il soit ainsi blond suédois
des amis qui sont roux enfin tout le
monde
voit pas ou qu'elles aient ou non on
vous réconciliera pas là dessus ça c'est
sûr pour certains c'est du racisme pour
d'autres ça n'est absolument pas
porteuse dernière question bertrand
dicaire dernière question comment sont
les relations aujourd'hui entre harry et
son père est ce qu'ils se parlent encore
est ce que c'est les relations sont
rompus ou si c'est fini alors écoutez il
aurait dû se voir pour un déjeuner lors
des obsèques juste après les obsèques du
prince philippe ils n'ont pas eu
l'occasion puisque le prince a est
directement a repris un avion ne pour
rejoindre l'amérique donc apparemment il
semble on nous fait croire que les
relations vont mieux je peux vous dire
en tout cas qu'ils ne sont absolument
pas attendue à balmoral pour noël pour
fêter noël n'ont pas fêté noël avec 1,9
à fêter noël avec la
dernière petite chose peut-être on dit
que la reine va mieux certes elle a
commencé la nouvelle avec joie elle
reçoit à nouveau en audience cris vers
allah reçu son médecin personnel dont on
a parlé ici qui est au coeur de la
royale médical bubble à elle l'a fait
chevalier c'est un conte de fées c'est
désormais en chevalier qui va veiller
sur la santé de sa souveraine et on dit
qu'elle se réjouisse prochainement
puisque le 9 janvier prochain et bien
kate middleton fête ses 40 ans et il
partait déjà on est bien nniversaire